when you try to have a society where
each individual is a god whose wishes
and proclivities and demands Trump the
good of humanity and Society you end up
with a predictable mess you end up with
Decay and collapse and confusion and
we've seen this confusion for a while
now a decade ago New York banned large
sodas in order to make everybody
skinnier and now they're mandating that
everybody treat obesity as if it's
natural and healthy but no matter what
the one thing politicians don't want to
do because it would diminish their power
is to let people make their own choices
and yeah that includes the freedom to
eat and drink to extraordinary excess
but also more importantly it includes
the freedom to criticize those who do